und herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren episode
das herunter gefallen
wir befinden uns hier schon im spiel ihr
seht ich bin level 1 weil diese nicht
gerade erst raus gekommen ist und der
arzt natürlich auch schönen titel
eingeblendet gesehen wir spielen heute
nicht normal fortnight sondern mit dem
eye tracker also ihr seht wo
habe ich grade auf die brüste geschaut
[Musik]
ja das ist halt das problem an diesem
treffer
ihr seht also heute ganz genau wo ich
hinschaue und als allererstes kann ich
euch noch mal eben hier was sagen und
zwar klickt mal hier oben auf itemshop
falls sie selber fordert spielt und dann
hier unten bei unterstütze einen vetter
will ich mich sehr freuen wenn ihr dort
luca eingeben würde dann steht hier oben
rechts unterstützt der creator luca und
immer wenn ihr euch was bei ford kaufte
bekomme ich ein wenig von dem geld ab
was an epic games geht also ihr zahlt
keinen cent mehr und könnte mich quasi
kostenlos unterstützen wir klicken jetzt
aber erst mal hier auf spielen sieht das
ganze jetzt aus wenn wir halt in dem
sinn bisher noch nicht richtig in game
sondern erst gerade noch in der lobby er
mir sieht ganz genau wo ich hier
wirklich die ganze zeit hinschauen
das heißt ich kann jetzt sagen ich gucke
auf den po und dann schaue ich auf den
hof und vielleicht ist es ja ganz
interessant dass hier mal seht wo so
richtige fortnight profis wie ich
überhaupt ihre augen hinschauen ob mein
gott es geht los ich dachte mir halt hey
ich bin wirklich ein erfahrener
fortnight spieler im spiel das spiel
schon echt sehr lange spielzeit wirklich
sehr lang und leben sprechen bin ich
auch wirklich sehr gut ich dachte es ist
vielleicht cool dass ihnen mal sehen wo
ich überhaupt hinschauen mein gott das
sind hier die neuen sachen ich würde
sagen wir gehen mal als erstes an die
steps in dieser runde dann gehen wir
gleich noch in diese neue lagune
ach guck mal da ist jetzt sogar somit
metern und so springt ja jetzt mal raus
und runter geht die kg ich habe auch
wieder den unauffälligsten skin aller
zeiten genommen hier und schauen wir uns
nochmal diesen neuen ort sunny steps
jahr nicht wollte eigentlich schon vor
einigen tagen mein video zur these
nature raushauen
allerdings hatte ich leider magen darm
und habe eigentlich den ganzen tag nur
gekotzt und gekackt bitteschön für diese
info an konnte ich leider noch kein
video aufnehmen ich kenne mich auch
dementsprechend noch überhaupt nicht in
dieser season hier aus und weiß
überhaupt nicht wie sie 9
das hat auf jeden fall viel sind ergeben
diese treppe abzubauen luca gab es schon
immer vögeln fortnight ich den profi
brauche ich denn jetzt fall schaden
bekommen
oh mein gott ich sage oh mein gott du
glaubst du mein gott
a
habe ich noch gut schaden gegeben ja war
spielen ist das neue runde neues glück
freunde wir bewegen uns diesmal dorthin
das ist diese neue lagune das ist ja
auch sie sollen dingen wo man drauf
springen kann man dann katapultiert das
ein hoch ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
was es mir bringt dass dieser antrag
jetzt mit dabei ist und was es euch
bringt das mit dabei ist aber ich dachte
mir hey vielleicht ist es wirklich wie
gesagt ganz cool es immer bei dem profi
seht wo ich hinschaue während die spiele
langsam reichts luca und sag mal diesen
neuen ort hier an
das ist also diese lucky lady lay
geisterschiff auch schon in der hälfte
durch ich dachte wirklich dass mit
dieser season jetzt mit dazu kommt dass
man im wasser endlich auch schwimmen
kann
bisher ist hat was er ja immer irgendwie
irre pinkl hoch ich sehe schon wieder
die ganzen kommentare von wegen hey luca
warum spielst du nicht mit kopfhörern
eheleute echte profis braucht keine
kopfhörer natürlich kann man mit
kopfhörern besser hören helfen wo kommen
die gegner aber bei mir ist es halt so
ich habe keine gegner dubai statt
ja ich wollte mich auf die treppe
springen ja nie aber meine ganze
bescheidenheit hierbei seite ich finde
die neue season echt ganz nah das ist
jetzt das zweite oder dritte mal dass
ich jetzt überhaupt eine runde spieler
aber ich finde dieses ganze piraten
dingen als ich finde ich sehr sehr sehr
sehr cool aber ich mag auch allgemein
piraten ja ich bin auch an karneval mal
als pirat gegangen
das liebe ich ja eher an fortnight und
an den web making menschen dort
matchmaking menschen genau wie geben
sich immer so unfassbar viel mühe und
sind so detailverliebt ich mein ich das
mal an
das hängt sogar piraten fischernetzen
hier sagen wir bewegen uns jetzt mal so
langsam ein bisschen in die zone die ist
nämlich jetzt schon wieder gewandert
was haben wir denn auch ein eiswagen der
tage anscheinend ein kleinunfall dass
jetzt diese atome totentempel da oben
glaubt aber jetzt muss ich ab heiliger
bimbam was machst du meintest du nein
macht doch keinen fall jetzt bin ich der
bürger vor
das war ja und findet mich aber rasch 7
kills alter so will habe ich meiner
ganzen karriere doch nicht gemacht aber
gute freunde eine neue runde neues glück
ich würde sagen wir springen diesmal
direkt in den vulkan rein ich weiß nicht
ob das eine gute idee ist aber wir
können sie einfach mal ausprobieren
ich mache mir jetzt schon einen
fallschirm auf und wenn man in den
vokalen reinschaut sieht man schon da
drin ist lava um ein god what the [ __ ]
hätte ich gar nicht gedacht dass man
hier einfügen kann ich dass ich sterbe
tiere auch okay ach da kann ich dann
rüber fliegen
ach so ja dann gehen wir jetzt mal
direkt hier zu den leuten und hauen hier
ja noch nicht wissen neue runde neues
glück freunde wir gehen wieder direkt in
den vulkan rein
ich muss aber ganz ehrlich sagen dass
ich dieses diesen aid bisher wirklich
als die geilste diesen sehe ich weiß bin
kein fordert kanal meine meinung
interessiert wahrscheinlich kein schwein
aber für mich ist es eine sehr sehr
geiles diesen beamten diesmal nicht
direkt in diesem quartal sondern hier
vorne ist aber wer baut sich denn ein
haus direkt an einen vulkan aber auch
auf thema zurückzukommen ich finde
dieses diesen wirklich sehr sehr sehr
sehr geil weil ich meine ich hab auch
geil gefunden als damals dass sie dazu
kam und auch der schnee hier hinten aber
jetzt halt mit piraten dings und diesen
neuen bäumen und das ist dass ich hätte
nur wirklich sehr sehr sehr sehr gern
irgendwann demnächst in diesen neun oder
so vielleicht hier so ein areal wo
einfach nur wasser ist wo man aber nicht
wenn man drauf felt stirbt so wie am
rande der map sondern dass man da halt
wirklich schwimmen kann und so weiter
und so fort und dann vielleicht mit
boten rumfahren et cetera pp wir sind
alle kisten schon gelüftet
das heißt irgendwo hier ist ein typ und
der ist da hinten
ich bin ja unfair ist ja auch gamer
gehen wir denn hin wie jedes mal
komplett an rand der map hier achter von
inseln hallo das ist so ein bisschen so
wie wenn das hier ist hogwarts und hier
wohnen hält versteht ihr was ich meine
na das hier ist das allerletzte hause am
arsch der welt ich glaube ich kann mich
keiner stören hallo kann ich reinig kopf
mal okay ja ich bin so stark weil meinem
klopfen backe das ganze haus das sieht
so aus wie in der schweiz oder in
süddeutschland oder so das ding ist also
ich kann es natürlich nicht beurteilen
weil ich selber nicht so häufig fordert
spiele aber an alle unter euch die
wirkliche regelmäßig oder täglich sogar
vorn mitspielen ist hilton tower sound-
also landen noch leute enthüllte towers
war früher war sehr solide
non-plus-ultra ort so hab die ganzen
sachen aber irgendwie habe ich das
gefühl dass mittlerweile diese neuen
orte gegen den sus hinzugefügt werden
halt viel interessanter sind also meines
erachtens nach ist hilton tower wirklich
komplett
leer gefegt irgendwie in letzter zeit
bringen hier mal eine falle an weil hier
wird auch save jemand herlaufen und zum
glück sieht die falle dann auch niemand
und das ist diese tanz bomben kommt
nochmal
[Musik]
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
ich wollte noch mal ganz kurz sagen zum
support creator coach da einige von
meinen zuschauern sich gefragt haben hey
luca wieso meinst du man kann dich
kostenlos mit etwas supporten aber dann
bekommst du trotzdem geld dafür da geht
es einfach darum dass wenn ihr bei
fortnight euch irgendwas kauft mit
viborg sei es jetzt einen skin für 800
wie bugs oder so dann von diesen 800 wie
wachsen hier so oder so zahlen würde
dann epic games gibt epic games mir was
ab so provisions technisch aber für euch
entsteht dabei quasi kein mehr ins geld
was ihr zahlen müsst also das in einem
ganz kurz zum thema support creator lka
unterstütze einen creator kommt hierbei
fortnight da mich dass einige gefragt
hatten und ich weiß ich bin ein
regelmäßiger fordert spieler und ich bin
auch nicht sonderlich gut in diesem
spiel ich meine ich bin eigentlich der
beste aber vielleicht doch nicht der
allerbeste deswegen will ich euch
natürlich auch nicht böse wenn ihr den
ford code von irgendeinem anderen stream
annimmt oder von einem anderen gamer
oder dann tief in georgia keine ahnung
was ist natürlich ein gutes recht da
selbst entscheiden zu dürfen
wer lässt denn eine sniper mit einem
schluss liegen aber ich brauche nicht
mehr als ein schuss also ich bin
natürlich böse wenn ihr den vortritt
supportact von einem anderen gamer
nehmen wie gesagt ich bin ich der
allerbeste fordert spieler allerdings
wollte ich ja demnächst auch mit strings
anfangen auftritt und da werde ich auf
jeden fall so ein fortnight learning
prozess durchlaufen und werde mir das
spiel selbst mit freunden dann im stream
besser bei bringen und dadurch halt auch
spielpraxis sammeln also das ist auf
jeden fall mein ziel so ein bisschen
aber ich hab mir gerade übrigens vom
turm gebaut und mich in dieses geschütz
gesetzt und jetzt kann ich ein paar
gegner ab
an der stelle möchte das heutige videos
auf werden in meiner lieben freund ich
habe mir einfach gedacht hey ich hab
diesen eye tracker jedoch an meinem
bildschirm kleben und ich wollte immer
wieder fordert hochladen warum bin ich
das ganze nicht einfach also wenn es
euch gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen
hoch da nutzt gerne luca als support
creator colt und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]